[Musik]
brisante neue erkenntnisse kremlkritiker
navalny wurde mit dem nerven kampfstoff
novacek vergiftet milliardenprogramm für
krankenhäuser
das bundeskabinett beschließt einen
krankenhaus zukunftsfonds trotz corona
in venedig beginnen die filmfestspiele
allerdings ohne fans am roten teppich
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den nachrichten an diesem mittwoch den
sport hat wieder norbert lehmann dabei
ein stück von mir
nun steht es fest der russische
oppositionspolitiker und putin-kritiker
alexei navalny ist vergiftet worden und
zwar mit dem chemischen nerven
kampfstoffen naughty dog das habe ein
speziallabor der bundeswehr zweifelsfrei
wie es heißt herausgefunden
die bundesregierung gab es am nachmittag
bekannt navalny war am zwanzigsten
august auf einem in russischen flug ins
koma gefallen
seit zehn tagen liegt er in der berliner
charité
christiane hübscher aus den ernsten
hinweisen ist gewissheit geworden putins
schärfster kritiker wurde vergiftet ein
speziallabor der bundeswehr hat sein
blut ausgewertet ein ergebnis von solch
politischer brisanz dass die kanzlerin
sofort vor die kameras geht
alexej nawalny wurde opfer eines
angriffs mit einem chemischen nerven
kampfstoff der nordgruppe dieses gift
lässt sich zweifelsfrei in den proben
nachweisen
er sollte zum schweigen gebracht werden
und ich verurteile das auch im namen der
ganzen bundesregierung auf das
allerschärfste der 44-jährige navalny
wird weiter auf der intensivstation der
berliner charité behandelt seit fast
zwei wochen liegt er im künstlichen koma
wird maschinell beatmet langzeitfolgen
nicht ausgeschlossen
mit dem gift new york wurden 2018 in
großbritannien schon der russische ex
spion skripal und seine tochter
vergiftet beide überlebten den anschlag
damals knapp nav eines anti korruptions
stiftung macht auch diesmal den
russischen staat verantwortlich
toxikologen sind gefragt wer kein navi
job herstellen
für die herstellung solcher stoffe
braucht man nicht unbedingt eine
staatliche infrastruktur man braucht
fundiertes chemisches wissen man braucht
schon ein gutes klinisches labor aber
man braucht kein hochsicherheitslabor
die bundesregierung wird außergewöhnlich
deutlich dieser fall erschüttert die
ohnehin schon angeschlagenen beziehungen
zu russland massiv auf grund
der neuen erkenntnisse hat die
bundesregierung heute nachmittag den
russischen botschafter erneut zu einem
dringenden gespräch ins auswärtige amt
eingeladen
ihm wurden dabei nochmals
unmissverständlich die aufforderung der
bundesregierung übermittelt
die hintergründe dieser nun
nachweislichen vergiftung von alexei
navalny vollumfänglich und in voller
transparenz aufzuklären und putin
reagiert die russische regierung sei
bereit mit berlin vollständig zu
kooperieren erklärt der kreml am abend
in moskau
fragen dazu an unsere korrespondenten in
berlin und moskau theo koll zuerst nav
ist ja nicht der erste der seine kritik
am system putin mit dem leben
beziehungsweise seiner gesundheit
bezahlt wie kann die bundesregierung
jetzt reagieren nun am ende bleibt es
eine politisch strategische entscheidung
aber zunehmend stellt sich hier auch die
frage einer menschlich moralischen
reaktion bei aller realpolitik muss die
bundesregierung jetzt entscheiden wie
massiv sie auf russlands immer länger
werdende spur der gewalt reagiert nicht
wenige experten raten dazu dem kreml mit
härte zu begegnen man müsse mit
sanktionen den preis für putins
aggressionen spürbar erhöhen
großbritannien und andere westliche
staaten hatten ja nach dem skript alle
anschlag damals mit einem vergleichbaren
kampfstoff eine große zahl russischer
diplomaten ausgewiesen und sanktionen
verhängt etwas vergleichbares wäre
sicher jetzt mindestens auch angemessen
und dass die bundesregierung und nicht
das krankenhaus heute die botschaft
überbracht hat und dass hier mit sehr
scharfen worten das deutet auch in diese
richtung
für begann in moskau bundeskanzlerin
merkel hat russland aufgefordert den
fallender wollen die dringend
aufzuklären ist dann zu erwarten dass er
tatsächlich was kommt wenn man sich
ähnlich gelagerte fälle der
vergangenheit anschaut dann ist damit
eigentlich nicht zu rechnen auch wenn
jetzt aus dem kreml eben die aussage
kommt man sei bereit zusammen zu
arbeiten
bisher erfolgt moskau dem sack mehl aus
dem skript anfall oder auch aus dem mord
des tiergarten bekannten musters erstens
empörung über die vorwürfe zweitens
seinerseits beweise einfordern
und drittens alternative negative in
umlauf bringen die dann schon mal
zweifel schüren sollen an den
ermittlungsergebnissen deutscher
behörden in diesem fall einen ganz
bedeutenden unterschied gibt es zum
bisherigen vorgehen nämlich dass eben
heute abend schon diese hochrangigen
reaktionen aus kremmen und dummer zu
hören sind auch das russische
außenministerium hat sich daher vor
getan und das wiederum sagte seinerseits
dass diese berliner erklärung
doch womöglich nur der versuch sein
schon lange im vorfeld beschlossenen
strafmassnahmen gegen russland zu
rechtfertigen
das ist also erstens natürlich ein
rhetorischer gegenschlag gegen berlin
aber dann auch schon mal der versuch
sich als opfer zu inszenieren für die
womöglich folgenden strafmaßnahmen und
dann ganz sicher auch der versuch
abzulenken vom kern dessen worüber wir
heute abend sprechen nämlich der
vergiftung eines oppositionspolitikers
die vergiftung alexej nawalny und die
frage nach den hintermännern dieser tat
danke für über danke theo vergiftet mit
einem nervenkampf stoff zum fallen der
ball nie haben wir die neuesten
entwicklungen und hintergründe
zusammengefasst etwa erkenntnisse über
anschläge mit der substanz naughty dog
und details über das gift selbst nach
paris wo heute ein historischer prozess
begonnen hat mehr als fünf jahre nach
einer anschlagsserie die ganz frankreich
erschüttert hatte nachdem das
satiremagazin charlie hebdo mohammed
karikaturen veröffentlicht hatte drangen
islamistische terroristen in die
redaktion ein und erschossen zwölf
menschen
ein weiterer attentäter nahmen geiseln
in einem jüdischen supermarkt und tötete
fünf menschen
alle terroristen wurden von der polizei
erschossen
auf der anklagebank sitzen ihre
mutmaßlichen helfer aus paris berichtet
thomas wald zum prozessbeginn druck
charlie hebdo noch einmal seine
mohammed-karikaturen und bekommt
unterstützung von höchster stelle im
staat
in frankreich gibt es die freiheit zur
blasphemie die ein teil der
gedankenfreiheit ist das zeigt die
dimension des prozesses der heute unter
strengen sicherheitsauflagen im
schwurgericht von paris begann die
fanatiker wollen uns die freiheit nehmen
denn sie hassen die freiheit 14
angeklagten werden beschuldigt
attentätern geholfen zu haben die in und
vor der redaktion von charlie hebdo
zwölf menschen töteten zudem sollen sie
einem islamisten geholfen haben der vier
menschen in einem koscheren supermarkt
umgebracht hatte und eine polizistin die
attentäter selbst wurden von der polizei
getötet die hinterbliebene eines
zeichners erhofft sich mehr als
strafrechtliche aufklärung dieser
prozess wird vielleicht die trauer und
den schmerz etwas lindern
vielleicht bringt das etwas zum
abschluss auf die attentate folgte eine
internationale welle der solidarität
dennoch bleiben einige der charlie hebdo
journalisten heute skeptisch zurück die
meinungsfreiheit in frankreich wurde
verloren es gibt sie noch auf dem papier
aber auf eigenes risiko wenn man den
propheten zeichnet und das gilt auch für
die internationale presse sehen sie sich
die new york times an oder die anderen
großen zeitungen die das thema komplett
aufgegeben haben 8000 radikalisierte
gefährder gebe es in frankreich hat
gerade der innenminister erklärt auch
die redaktion von charlie abdo bleibt
bedroht der kampf der getöteten
karikaturisten und journalisten um die
freiheit lebt weiter schauen wir auf die
korona zahlen in deutschland die zahl
der gemeldeten neuinfektionen ist weiter
leicht gesunken
im durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben
tage haben sich täglich 1200 menschen
mit dem virus angesteckt gestern waren
es noch 1240 deutschlands krankenhäuser
sind im vergleich zu anderen ländern
recht gut durch die krone zeit gekommen
obwohl sie nicht gerade üppig da stehen
im gegenteil
seit langem schon fehlt es an geld um in
ausstattung und digitalisierung zu
investieren
das hd pandemie jetzt besonders deutlich
gemacht mit drei milliarden euro will
jetzt die bundesregierung das problem
angehen florian berichtet da ist zum
beispiel diese kinderklinik in
bremerhaven den auftrag kinder zu
behandeln haben sie seit anfang des
jahres bezahlen mussten sie den bau
dafür aber selbst leider warten wir bis
heute noch um über auf die finanzierung
dieser baumaßnahme denn bis heute haben
wir dazu kein signal bekommen
so sind hier mit 4,3 millionen euro in
vorleistung getreten
geld das dann bei der versorgung der
patienten fehlt wie an so vielen stellen
im land diagnose chronischer geldmangel
bei deutschlands kliniken
seit 1991 haben die bundesländer immer
weniger in die ausstattung der
krankenhäuser investiert - 16 prozent
jährlich fehlen nach angaben der
krankenhausgesellschaft 3 milliarden
euro ein lange bekanntes problem durch
corona plötzlich für alle sichtbar klar
geworden ist in dieser pandemie dass es
defizite gibt insbesondere bei der
digitalisierung im gesundheitswesen in
den verschiedensten bereichen auch in
den kliniken da will nun die
bundesregierung ein springen mit
einmalig 3 milliarden euro aus dem
bundeshaushalt zum beispiel für digitale
vernetzung oder it sicherheit von
krankenhäusern richtig aber viel zu
wenig meint die opposition das ist erst
der erste schritt in richtung
digitalisierung der krankenhäuser die
hätte schon vor jahren stattfinden
müssen denn die länder sind ihrer
finanziellen verpflichtungen nicht
nachgekommen
gesundheitsminister sparen nutzt seine
pressekonferenz heute aber auch für
grundsätzliche anmerkungen in sachen
corona
wir haben echt ziemlich viel erreicht
bis hierhin die zahlen sind niedrig das
gesundheitswesen kann gut damit umgehen
und wir wissen wie wir uns schützen und
damit können bei recht zuversichtlich in
herbst und winter gehen geschäfte
flächendeckend zu schließen sei im
frühjahr richtig gewesen noch einmal
meint zumindest sparen heute aber wäre
das so nicht passieren
der missbrauchsfall von bergisch
gladbach zieht immer weitere kreise
nach razzien in zwölf bundesländern
gestern zog die polizei heute bilanz die
ermittler stellten
mehr als 2000 beweismittel sicher vor
allem datenträger den 50 verdächtigen
wird besitz und verbreitung
kinderpornografischen materials
vorgeworfen
insgesamt gibt es in dem fall inzwischen
deutschlandweit mehr als 200
beschuldigte amnesty international
erhebt schwere vorwürfe gegen iran nach
den demonstrationen im vergangenen jahr
seien inhaftierte gefoltert und
misshandelt worden
auch um geständnisse zu erzwingen die
wut über höhere benzinpreise hatte sich
im november zu landesweiten protesten
entwickelt mst geht von tausenden
festnahmen aus mehrere menschen seien
seither verschwunden
in bulgarien eu und nato mitglied gibt
es seit monaten massive proteste die
demonstranten und die oppositionellen
sozialisten verlangen den rücktritt der
regierung
der zorn richtet sich vor allem gegen
ministerpräsident borissov der heute
auch noch eine umstrittene
verfassungsänderung auf den weg bringen
wollte wolf christian ullrich
laut starke proteste heute früh vor dem
parlament in sofia wütende demonstranten
machen den abgeordneten druck die polin
verfassungsänderungen auf den weg
bringen mit ihnen ministerpräsident
borissov in dieser dauerkrise seine
regierung retten will und das lehnen die
demonstranten ab wir wollen zuallererst
rechtsstaatlichkeit und wir wollen leute
im parlament die sich an recht und
gesetz halten war selena dabei ist von
beginn an teil der protestbewegung seit
knapp zwei monaten fordern sie borissov
zum rücktritt auf sie werfen ihm
korruption vor und allzu enge nähe zu
oligarchen boris auf selbst reist der
bei durchs land verteilt finanzielle
wohltaten und versucht händeringend die
oberhand zu halten
wir brauchen eine neue verfassung
verkündete er jüngst es sei zeit für
einen neustart des staates mit seiner
verfassungsänderung will er das
parlament halbieren und eine umfassende
justizreform durchsetzen
der generalstaatsanwalt den die
demonstranten als teil des korruptions
systems sehen soll plötzlich gesetze
vorschlagen dürfen beobachter sind
alarmiert die änderungen sind gefährlich
hier geht es um die auflösung der
gewaltenteilung
trotz der proteste hat die koalition das
verfahren im parlament heute auf den weg
gebracht während dessen eskalierte
draußen die lage für den abend sind
weitere großdemos angesagt die wut ist
groß in bulgarien im streit um eine 500
millionen euro teure batterie zellfabrik
in münster übt der bundesrechnungshof
scharfe kritik am forschungsministerium
im auswahlverfahren habe münster mehr
informationen bekommen als mitbewerber
vergabekriterien seien unklar gewesen
forschungsministerin carlitscheck räumte
fehler ein
sie versprach künftig würden relevante
informationen bei großverfahren an alle
bewerber weitergegeben
nach den dieselmotoren nimmt die
deutsche umwelthilfe nun auch
hybridautos aufs korn
solche fahrzeuge kombinieren einen
verbrennungsmotor
nach angaben der hersteller macht sie
das deutlich sparsamer und weniger
umweltbelastend leider nein sagt die
umwelthilfe
die selbst nach gemessen hat verbrauch
und schadstoffausstoß seien häufig um
ein vielfaches höher als angegeben
nils schneider berichtet immer mehr plug
in hybride sind in deutschland unterwegs
die zahl der neuzulassungen pro monat
ist von fast 9000 im januar auf mehr als
19.000 im juli geklettert die deutsche
umwelthilfe hat nun ein modell von
porsche mercedes und zwei volvo getestet
der ausstoß von co2 abgasen war
teilweise bis zum sechsfachen höher als
vom hersteller angegeben wenn der
elektromotor aus war
wir fordern ein ende der finanziellen
förderung von plug in hybriden als
dienstwagen
wir fordern auch dass es für solche
fahrzeuge keine kaufprämien mehr gibt
der verband der deutschen
automobilindustrie widerspricht heftig
wirft der umwelthilfe vor nicht seriös
gemessen zu haben
die deutsche umwelthilfe verlässt damit
den boden der seriösen diskussion jeder
weiß dass hybride heute bis zu 70
kilometer elektrisch geladen fahren
können
es ist ein wichtiges instrument vielen
menschen den weg in die elektromobilität
zu erreichen
plug in hybride sind so beliebt da
käufer momentan vom staat bis zu 6000
750 euro elektro förderung dazu kommen
für dienstwagen sind weitere
steueranreize möglich
verbraucherschützer bemängeln bisher
dauere es zu lange e autos oder plugins
zu bestellen und vor allem zu laden
man braucht aber auch zur sicherheit
eine gute ladeinfrastruktur da gibt es
auch bemühungen das auszubauen
die verbraucher brauchen aber auch eine
sicherheit dass das wirklich die technik
der zukunft ist plug in hybride können
ein weg zu mehr umwelt schonen der e
mobilität sein
zuviel ausstoß von klimaschädlichem co2
würde aber eher das gegenteil erreichen
und gerade kam nochmal eine eilmeldung
in sachen corona wegen der gestiegenen
zahl von neuinfektionen hat die
bundesregierung auch die kanarischen
inseln und damit ganz spanien als
risikogebiet eingestuft
das hat das robert-koch-institut gerade
bekannt gegeben und nun großes kino
trotzt caron
wir schauen nach venedig zum ältesten
filmfestival der welt und zum ersten
bedeutsamen das in pandemie zeiten wie
geplant stattfindet wenn auch mit
einschränkungen etwa auf dem roten
teppich mimen mit masken und ohne cate
blanchett zum beispiel stars also sind
da der gedanke an das virus allerdings
auch dennoch venedig feiert zum 77 mal
die filmkunst und die fantasie andreas
postel als prominentester gast ist zum
auftakt der filmfestspiele cate
blanchett auf den lido gekommen wegen
der vielen absagen aus hollywood bedingt
durch corona und die oscar verschiebung
ist alles im großen festivalkalender
durcheinandergeraten cate blanchett ist
als vorsitzender der jury dankbar dass
venedig dem corona virus trotz jedes mal
wenn du anfängst wirfst du alles über
den haufen was du feuer gemacht hat es
liegt in der dna von uns künstlern sich
auf neue situationen einzustellen
starke frauen geben in diesem krisenjahr
den ton an
von den 18 wettbewerbsbeiträgen haben
fast die hälfte eine weibliche
handschrift und auch der goldene löwe
für das lebenswerk geht in diesem jahr
an eine frau an oscar preisträgerin
tilda swinton auch ihre mimik verborgen
ein venezianischer maskenball
festivaldirektor alberto barbera hat
sich entschieden für absperrungen
temperaturmessung und limitierten
einlass ab einem bestimmten punkt haben
wir uns überlegt dass es wichtig ist zu
eröffnen um ein positives signal zu
setzen um die filmbranche zu
unterstützen einen längeren lockdown
kann sich das kino nicht leisten
schünemann und probieren und so
appellieren er und seine europäischen
festival leiter zum auftakt eindringlich
an die zusammenhalt der filmbranche
das 77 filmfestival hier in venedig auf
dem lido steht ganz im zeichen der
korona pandemie ein schmaler grat
zwischen sicherheitsabstand und
kommunikativer nähe von dem ein festival
lebt es ist ein mutiger akt der
selbstbehauptung für eine zutiefst
verunsicherte branche und ein zeichen
der hoffnung dass das kino lebt der
eröffnungsfilm am abend der beitrag
lötzschs ii ein italienisches
familiendrama und ein festlicher auftakt
für alle chinesen nicht nur in venedig
und nun zum sport und zur norbert da
gibt es morgen das den auftakt zum
nations league spiel deutschland gegen
spanien genau übrigens zu sehen bei uns
im zdf 20.15 live bundestrainer joachim
löw plant beim ersten deutschen
länderspiel nach fast zehn monaten mit
debütant robin großes als
linksverteidiger mit kevin trapp im tor
und natürlich mit seinem spielgestalter
toni kroos toni kroos ist kapitän im
löw-team bayerns triple-sieger um manuel
neuer sind beim nations league auftrag
nicht dabei eine art vorspiel zur em im
nächsten jahr natürlich ist das ein
offizieller wettbewerb aber das
natürlich irgendwie dieses hauptziel em
am ende der tage ist und da müssen wir
von anfang an finde ich jedes spiel
nutzen um das vorzubereiten
die häuserner kehrt in stuttgart nach
verletzung in die startelf zurück die
auf grund stark unterschiedlicher
spielpraxis wohl nicht zu ende spielen
wird ich glaube nicht dass die spieler
so in der lage 90 minuten irgendwie
hohen rhythmus zu gehen das wird
vielleicht beim ein oder andere gelinge
beim anderen wahrscheinlich nicht zum
ersten mal in der deutschen
länderspiel-geschichte wird vor leeren
rängen gespielt corona bedingt rb
leipzig kann ja seit gestern für den
ersten bundesliga-spieltag mit 8500
stadionbesuchern plan die reaktion heute
auf die entscheidung überwiegend positiv
auch andere vereine haben zuschauer
pläne für leipzig wichtigste auflage für
die zuschauer beim heimspiel gegen mainz
es muss mund und nasenschutz getragen
werden beim betreten des stadions
die tickets sollen unter den dauerkarten
besitzern in sachsen verlost werden auch
andere bundesliga klubs planen für den
dfb pokal am übernächsten wochenende mit
publikum schauen deshalb mit interesse
auf das leipziger modell das was ich ein
feedback bekommen habt war mehr zuspruch
als das können wir nicht nachvollziehen
weil jeder natürlich auch möchte das in
seinem stadion wieder die eigenen fans
kommen dürfen wolfsburgs geschäftsführer
jörg schmadtke dagegen warnt vor
wettbewerbsverzerrung wenn ein verein
vor zuschauern spielen darf und andere
weiterhin vor leeren rängen allerdings
ich denke wir alle sollten daran
arbeiten das ist sukzessive wieder
möglich sein wir jetzt unsere fans in
die stadien zu lassen
morgen auf der dfl tagung wird sich
zeigen welchen weg die bundesliga
vereine gehen wollen hin zu einem stück
normalität bei den us open in new york
hat angelique kerber soeben die dritte
runde erreicht
im deutschen duell besiegte sie die 26
jährige anna lena friedsam nach einem
hart umkämpften match mit 6 3 und 7 6
das was von mir danke wir haben noch
einen besonderen fangen der von der
nordseeküste gemeldet wird auf borkum
hat ein neunjähriger junge ein lebendes
seepferdchen aus dem hafenbecken
gefischt eine sehr seltene beute gilt
auch das tierchen im wattenmeer seit 90
jahren als ausgestorben
neue gesellschaft für die vielfältigen
art genossen im benachbarten aquarium wo
es hoffentlich nett aufgenommen wird
wir haben jetzt noch die lottozahlen für
sie die gewinnzahlen lauten 6 10 23 39
45 49 und die superzahl 3 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto zdf de
und im zdf text auf seite 55 7
das wetter wird wieder ein bisschen
schöner im osten zieht der regen ab im
westen allerdings neuer auf wie es im
detail aussieht sehen sie gleich besten
terry so viel von uns mehr zum fallen
der ball nie dann im heute journal gegen
22 uhr 15 mit marietta slomka
wir danken für ihr interesse wünschen
noch einen angenehmen abend und sagen
tschüss bis morgen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter im osten
deutschlands lässt der regen allmählich
nach das tief ihr was vorherrschen
fahren nimmt das regengebiet mit ein
neues regengebiet kommt von westen her
mit einem neuen tief auf und dieser
regen setzt sich etwa bis zur mitte
deutschlands durch in der nacht regnet
es von der oder bis zur neiße sonst ist
es trocken im südosten bildet sich nebel
die tiefsten temperaturen liegen
zwischen 5 und 9 grad im süden und 14
grad an der ostsee morgen am vormittag
gibt es im osten schauer
die ziehen allmählich ab von westen her
kommen neue wort münsterland mit regen
ansonsten ist viel sonnenschein dabei
bis in den süden deutschlands und zum
nachmittag denen sich die wolken weiter
aus und dann regnet es auch bis ins
saarland im osten ist es trocken sowie
im süden die höchsten temperaturen
liegen bei 24 grad in sachsen anhalt und
im südwesten deutschlands 16 grad sind
es an der nordsee die nächsten tage gibt
es schauer im norden deutschlands die
durchziehen 19 bis 28 grad am freitag
und am samstag wird es von nordwesten
her allmählich kühler und sonntag nur
noch 16 bis 21 grad da zuschauer damit
ein schöner abend